the author of ten solid weeks in a row
the number one best-selling book in the
country the number one selling book for
the entire year american marxism the
great one i call him mark levin great
one i'll let you just take it from here
because i can't name a single thing joe
biden is doing
that's working maybe you can
uh no i can't thank you sean what's
going on is american marxism we better
call it what it is and what's going on
here but it's
i want to talk about something specific
that's illustrative of what's going on
in this country we have open borders
that violates federal statutes
nobody's holding any hearings on that
because they don't care that joe biden's
violating the law
joe biden has put in place critical race
theory throughout this government
violates in my view the equal protection
part of the 14th amendment and the 1964
civil rights act
this genderism which violates the rights
of little girls and and women who
participate in athletes and so for in
athletics and so forth
you can see how they're trying to
legislate in secret they keep talking
about the so-called progressives and
moderates working out a deal the only
people who are cut out is we the people
we're not involved in this deal they
keep threatening the independence of the
supreme court of course
we have murder through the roof we have
our enemies on the move communist china
fascistic russia
the islamic regime in tehran and of
course the
the inbred there in north korea and
what's the house of representatives
focused on
making inflation worse spending
trillions more and then nancy pelosi has
set up a little soviet type of pull-up
bureau called this january 6 committee
in which she only allowed people on the
committee who already decided that
donald trump is guilty of something
and so we have reprobates on this
committee like liz cheney i remember
when
people used to talk about wanting her
father in prison you remember that sean
i remember when people were very upset
and said that her father had lied about
the intelligence information and i don't
remember any special committee put
together to investigate any of that
liz cheney's not investigating what
happened in afghanistan she's not
investigating all the ms-13 and drugs
coming across the border she's not
investigating threats against the u.s
supreme court or anything of the sort
she's lost her mind she's unhinged and
i'm picking on her specifically as an
example of what is a soviet-style
committee set up by a speaker of the
house who's chasing after an
ex-president of the united states the
only kind of regimes that do this sort
of thing mal used to do this of course
stalin used to do this castro used to do
this they go after people who are no
longer in office they try to use the
power of the government has anybody been
charged on january 6 with insurrection
they keep calling this an insurrection
nobody has anybody been charged with
sedition nobody has anybody been charged
with trees and nobody so why do they
keep calling it an insurrection the only
person killed on january 6 was an
innocent protester who wasn't violent in
the least the fbi already said there was
no plot so what is this committee that
nancy pelosi has put together what is
this committee actually doing well it's
the worst attack on our democracy in
history no it's not the greatest threat
to our country is not what happened on
january 6th it's what happens every day
the democratic party and their
surrogates and mouthpieces in the media
that's the worst attack on this country
our economic system our representative
governing system and so forth
that's the greatest threat that we face
did people see merrick garland testify
today they have two types of people that
they appoint in this administration
radical marxist kooks and feeble types
now here you have merrick garland that
doesn't know anything that's going on
there was a real insurrection at the
interior department last week merrick
garland was unaware of it utterly
unaware of it it was they pushed through
they injured a police officer nobody
gives a damn when the portland
courthouse a federal courthouse was
attacked night after night for over two
months with fire bombs with with all
kinds of stuff when we're police were
under attack who nancy pelosi called
storm troopers merrick garland says well
that's not domestic terrorism because
nobody was there it was happening at
night meanwhile they go after parents
liz cheney concerned about that not in
the least now we have a big problem in
this country ladies and gentlemen we
have a rogue presidency we have a rogue
department of justice we have an
out-of-control democrat-controlled house
by three votes the democrat controls
senate 50-50 by the luck of the
constitution the vice president breaks
the tie and what do they want to do what
do they say they want to do
fundamentally transform our economic
system well you have a choice you have a
free market economic system
that you have in free countries that
respects individuals creates growth and
wealth for individual human beings to
work their way up the ladder
or you have a centralized
marxist type socialist economic system
where morons in washington dc either who
work for the civil service not all but
enough and the politicians decide who
gets what now where does that work where
has that ever worked did it work in
cuber did it work in venezuela does it
work anywhere where it's tried no and
they're doing it in secrecy and by god
we have to get it done by october 31st
why
because joe biden is going to be at some
big meeting i think it's a climate
change meeting where he wants to talk
about climate change so we've got to
fundamentally transform our economic
system our governing system destroy your
freedom destroy your lifestyle by
october 31 so joe biden can jet off to a
climate change meeting this government
is dysfunctional many of the democrats
are out of their minds some of the
republicans are out of their minds the
media are corrupt we need a big
fumigation effort here so in the next
election we have to throw these bums out
and the election after that we have to
throw this dollaring all fool in the
oval office out
that's it
that's why we call you the great one
mark